bonsoir soit alors tariq ramadan vous
êtes professeur de philosophie au
collège de genève et d'islamologie à
l'université de fribourg
auteur de nombreux ouvrages consacrés à
l'islam conférencier et vos
interventions sont largement diffusé
sous forme de cassette
ce qui fait qu'on emploie souvent à
votre sujet le terme de prédicateurs
alors j'étais un personnage assez
charismatique orateurs star des jeunes
musulmans et et d'après le journal le
monde vos écrits vos cassettes aurait
influencé lilas et alma voilà donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé de venir parce
que en fait c'est j'écoute effectivement
des cassettes de monsieur par parmi
d'autres moi j'aime bien ces cas c'est
ce que je vais dire aussi c'est que je
tiens à insister sur le fait qu on a
commencé à apprendre apprendre l'islam
après avoir commencé à le pratiquer
parce que justement on voulait était
déjà a précisé à plusieurs reprises
corriger notre pratique parce
qu'effectivement on pratiquer sans
science que la tradition orale quoi
voilà voilà exactement
oui moi j'aimerais dire par rapport à la
façon dont vous m'avez présenter je
crois que c'est particulièrement
nécessaire il est particulièrement
nécessaire d'insister sur une chose
c'est à dire que systématiquement quand
des citoyens français de confession
musulmane peuvent entendre un discours
qui est un conte un discours qui leur
envoient leur esprit critique on dit
deux choses d'une part quand ce discours
il a un impact c'est une star et vous
savez ce que peut vouloir la connotation
du thermostat c'est un tout petit peu
idole quand je suis en fait non non non
non non je peux comprendre que ce soit
bien cela étant dans le temps dans la
dimension religieuse star c'est un peu
guru guru c'est un peu quelqu'un qui
prive celui qui l'écoutent de l'esprit
critique il aurait mais je crois que
c'est tout à fait fou et on le voit ce
soir je dire que moi ce qui me paraît
très important entendre aujourd'hui
c'est que les français de confession
musulmane jeunes femmes ou jeunes hommes
homme ou femme parce qu'il faut arrêter
de les appeler jeunes c'est un autre
temps qu'on utilise tout le temps c'est
à dire qu'un processus d'infantilisation
reste jeunes jusqu'à 40 ans parmi les
musulmans
alors que chez les autres et leurs
interlocuteurs se serait ce serait plus
précoce je crois qu'à partir d'un
certain moment on a une population
aujourd'hui qui est en train de revenir
à des références religieuses car un
esprit critique parmi ceux qui
reviennent à la pratique religieuse en
france la majorité sont des étudiants
c'est pas des laissés pour compte c'est
pas des paumés des banlieues c'est des
gens qui ont un esprit critique qui se
construisent alors évidemment quand on
n'a pas la langue arabe et qu'on revient
à l'islam on passe par ce qu'on appelle
du bricolage mais qu'est la construction
de l'esprit critique par la langue
française il n'y a pas de problème alors
tariq ramadan en mai dernier dans
libération s'est déclaré pas de lois
contre le foulard
moi j'avais d'abord écrire un article
avec un titre très clair qui était une
lettre ouverte à monsieur sarkozy à
monsieur ferry c'est le journal
libération qui a changé le titre qui a
ciblé sur la question du foulard parce
que ma thèse fondamentale c'est un peu
dans le sens de ce que vous avez dit
c'est qu'aujourd'hui cette question du
foulard
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est à
dire que effectivement depuis dix ans le
nombre de cas n'ont pas augmenté et que
la laïcité dans sa règle ne s'opposait
pas à la pratique religieuse à partir du
moment où respecter trois règles celles
que vous avez rappelé pas de
prosélytisme pas de trouble à l'ordre
public et pas de dispense de courtet qui
font assister à tous les coins
une fois que cela est dit le conseil
d'état dit une chose qui est très
importante et je pense qu'il faudrait
qu'on en prenne acte au cas par cas vous
ne pouvez pas savoir quand une
conscience est contrainte si elle est
pas en intégrisme potentiel ou si elle
est par un choix individuel est à dire
un acte de conscience et ça se voit
comment ça se voit quand on discute avec
les gens non je ne peux pas savoir si
vous êtes vous même sous l'affluence
d'un gourou des médias jean claude
coudouy par exemple et donc ma thèse
elle était de dire aux deux ministres
concernés le problème du foulard n'est
pas l'essentiel le problème c'est
véritablement un travail de fond dans la
politique sociale de ce pays parce
qu'effectivement silice l'islam n'est
pas tout le problème
mais il ya un problème avec l'islam
effectivement mais il ya des problèmes
d'intégration de discrimination à
l'emploi de discrimination à
l'instruction c'est ça le vrai problème
vous c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt se
foule alors alors c'est évident
qu'aujourd'hui or vous savez je crois
qu'il ya une chose dont il faut qu'on se
rende compte en france la france est en
danger de la normalisation d'un certain
nombre de thèses d'extrême droite et en
particulier par rapport à la question de
l'islam elle appelle questions des
français d'origine immigrée
parce que on eu depuis jusqu'à qu'on va
parler de français d'origine immigrée
la seule différence entre en français de
souche dans ce pays et un français
d'origine immigrée
c'est que le français de souche
immigré de plus longue date c'est tout
c'est comme ça qu'il faut envisager la
question
il faut arrêter de normaliser ses thèses
d'exclusion et je crois que quelque
chose qui est très importante qui a été
dit aujourd'hui ici sur ce plateau à
savoir on ne pourra pas faire l'économie
d'un dialogue au cas par cas et surtout
restaurer la confiance entre l'état
l'autorité publique est les citoyens de
confession musulmane dans ce pays
aujourd'hui un déficit de
conditionnement un problème c'est que le
l'islam contrairement à d'autres
religions englobe tout il englobe la vie
sociale aussi beaucoup plus que que le
que le catholicisme ou le judaïsme non
alors ce que j'aimerais dire par rapport
à cela c'est que je crois pas je crois
qu'on a une idée on dit oui ils font pas
de différence entre tous les dimensions
de leur vie je crois simplement une
chose c'est qu'effectivement une femme
ou un homme de confession musulmane
pratiquante ou pratiquants par la force
des choses vous allez voir ça à paraître
dans son quotidien
les cinq prières par jour le jeûne on va
venir dans le jeune c'est dans deux
semaines par la force des choses c'est
visible à une visibilité mais je crois
pas qu'ils aient beaucoup de différences
entre n'importe quel plus englobant que
les autres religions
elle peut elle peut apparaître comme tel
mais finalement un catholique pratiquant
et juif pratiquant je veux dire il est
avec dieu le dimanche le samedi et avec
le diable la semaine ils essaient
simplement d'être cohérent dans sa
pratique c'est à dire d'avoir une
éthique de vie et c'est ça la
spiritualité réelles des gens alors
évidemment on n'est pas habitué à cette
éthique musulmane
on n'est pas habitués à la présence du
musulman parmi nous eh bien il va
falloir s'y habituer c'est que la france
a changé
je crois que tout le monde a compris
mais non mais je crois qu'il n'a pas
compris ce que vous dire aussi que
c'était encore pire pour les filles qui
qui seraient appréciés par leurs
familles qui seraient contraintes à
porter le voile parce qu'elles sont les
retire de l'école de leur appui des
caisses qui les attend on la remet chez
les intégristes sapho faut être cohérent
mais au moins on la laisse à l'école ça
va lui permettre d'acquérir des diplômes
une situation et éventuellement une
émancipation et s'est fait fait peur oui
moi j'aimerais c'est logique
oui je crois que là aussi parce qu'on a
entendues par exemple de sos racisme un
temps on disait mot maintenant une loi
aux il faut pas les accepter à l'école
puis qu'ils fassent des des écoles
islamiques veux dire c'est le pire qu'on
puisse imaginer véritablement une école
islamique ce peut être le ghetto faut
arrêter avec ça aujourd'hui
l'islam n'est pas en cause dans la
violence des banlieues
l'islam n'est pas en cause dans le
traitement qu'il y à des jeunes filles
aujourd'hui est des viols collectifs
c'est souvent d'ailleurs des jeunes qui
ne se connaissent pas leur religion qui
sont en mal sur le plan de l'intégration
sociale en discrimination à l'emploi en
discrimination même dans l'instruction
il faut également qu'on dise de ce point
de vue là qu'il ya un vrai problème il
faut pas qu'on nie les problèmes je
crois qu'il ya aussi de la part des
citoyens de confession musulmane d'un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles
il faut qu'il réponde
là on n'est pas en train de jouer il
faut surtout pas qu'on commence une
d'entrer dans une ère de victimisation
là moi je suis aussi très ferme avec le
public musulman il ya des vraies
questions à poser sur la discrimination
vis-à-vis des femmes
il ya des vrais problèmes à poser sur le
fait que des jeunes culture de lac de
culture arabe peuvent entretenir un
machisme en utilisant l'islam contre les
jeunes ça c'était inacceptable il faut
qu'on le dise et en plus hier qu'est ce
qu'on disait de ces jeunes filles on
disait c'est le père ou le frère et vous
savez ce qu'on leur dit aujourd'hui on
leur dit elle son auto aliéné c'est
encore pire
c'est à dire que maintenant c'est par
leur propre choix qu'elle sami yen le
processus de libération des femmes
jamais en sortir bien avec ce sera le
mot de la fin on n'ira pas beaucoup plus
loin ce soir je vous remercie beaucoup
mesdemoiselles vous êtes est très jolie
sinon merci mouloud g alors de rester
avec moi au revoir on va
tariq ramadan
vous êtes très critiquée par certains on
vous accuse parfois de double discours
on dit que vous êtes un fondamentaliste
moderne comme ça et que finalement vous
avez une vieille rhétorique mais qu'elle
est bien emballé et est bien présente et
faut dire que votre grand père était
fondateur des frères musulmans en egypte
et votre frère hani ramadan a été
suspendu d'enseignement après avoir
justifié la lapidation des femmes
adultères et assimilés le sida un
châtiment divin alors quelle est votre
position par rapport à votre grand père
et par rapport à votre frère d alors
alors bon je vous remercie d'abord de
commencer par cela parce que ça me
permet de répéter ce que je dis mais
cette fois ci encore de façon plus
explicite
j'ai par rapport à mon à mon grand-père
l'attitude de n'importe quel esprit
critique vis-à-vis d'une histoire c'est
à dire que je le remets dans son
contexte des années 30 et des années 40
il y a des choses pour lesquelles j'ai
un énorme respect 2000 écoles créer un
travail fait pour les pauvres de
l'alphabétisation la résistance à la
colonisation
je crois qu'un esprit qui s'est levé
contre la colonisation est à ce prix un
esprit de dignité puis à des réponses
qu'il a données pour sont en 1940 sur le
registre éthique sur le registre
religieux qui doivent être mises et et
contextualisés quant à mon frère j'ai
effectivement mis souvent en évidence le
fait que sur un certain nombre de thèses
fondamental nous n'étions pas d'accord
et j'ai pris
j'ai une attitude critique et sélective
et une attitude de distanciation donc
encore une fois ce que j'ai toujours dit
à mes détracteurs depuis 20 ans que je
parle et avec une vingtaine de bouquin
publié
je vous demande une seule chose sinon
vous n'êtes pas crédible montrez-moi
clairement où ce double langage se situe
à quel moment j'ai pu la voir parce que
je dis à plus forte raison à tous ceux
qui m'écoutent de ces français et
européens de confession musulmane que la
chose contre laquelle il faut absolument
que nous luttions aujourd'hui nous en
tant que musulman c'est ce double
langage justement c'est un langage à la
mosquée entre nous et un langage sur la
place publique avec nos interlocuteurs
les pointures de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu